Art, you've asked one of the most important
questions in modern physics.
Is time real or is it an illusion?
Well, time is certainly real, but the question
is, what do we mean by the word time?
And it may surprise you that physicists don't
have a simple answer for that.
One thing we are absolutely sure of is that
the rate of time does change.
Time is not just simply a progression, like
a river that keeps flowing.
It can change depending on how fast you're
moving through space.
And this is Einstein's special theory of relativity.
The idea is that the faster you go, the slower
time appears to be moving for you if other
observers look at you going by.
So if you're on a spaceship going half the
speed of light, you don't perceive any change
yourself.
You perceive time going ahead just as you
always have felt it, but if people look at
you in the spaceship going by, And not just
you moving, but the vibrations of your atoms.
Any way you can possibly measure time is slowed
down.
As you go faster and faster and approach the
speed of light, your time slows down more
and more.
And the amazing thing is that at the speed
of light, time does not progress at all.
So this is something that has always kind
of freaked me out because there's light in
this room right now.
That there's light bouncing off my body.
That's the way you can see me.
I can look up at the sky and see the Sun.
Light does not experience time.
It's something that actually exists outside
of time, and yet we still interact with it.
And I've never found the right way to think
about that.
This effect is not just a theory.
This is incredibly well measured every single
day.
We accelerate things in particle accelerators
to very close to the speed of light, and all
the processes in physics slow down as that
happens.
Applications to this, too.
For example, the global positioning satellites
that allow you to take your location from
your smartphone.
Those satellites are going overhead very,
very fast.
They're going at nearly 20,000 miles an hour.
And it turns out that that's fast enough that
their time is slowed down.
They're actually in a slightly different time
frame than we are.
And we have to account for that.
We have to correct for that mathematically.
Otherwise, you would not get the right location.
So we know that time slows down.
We observe this happening all around us.
It was a really hard thing in modern physics
about 100 years ago for people to let go of
the idea that time just has a rate that it
flows-- that, in fact, it can flow at different
rates for different observers.
Then there's the question of what is time
related to space?
And you may have heard that Einstein talked
about a concept called space-time.
He didn't believe that space and time were
separate things.
We certainly perceive them differently in
our human brains.
We can move through space, but time always
seems to go just at one rate and in one direction.
But Einstein thought they were part of a fabric.
They were woven together.
And one of the ways he illustrated this was
that you have to adjust space and time so
they always kind of balance out.
If I am not moving through space-- I'm sitting
here still in this chair-- then time just
seems to go forward at a natural rate.
Time just flows.
But if I start going faster and faster, my
time slows down.
So in a sense, I'm moving through space very
fast.
So I can't move through time as fast as I
might have.
The two balance each other, space-time.
If you move through space very fast, time
begins to slow down, and they become the same
thing.
And now something gets even stranger, and
that is that Einstein thought that the beginning
of the universe-- the big bang-- created all
of space and all of time at once in a big
whole something-- So every point in the past
and every point in the future are just as
real as the point of time you feel yourself
in right now.
Einstein believed that literally.
One of his best friends died, and he wrote
a letter to this person's wife, talking about
how his friend still exists.
Time is a landscape, and if you had the right
perspective on the universe, you would see
all of it laid out in front of you-- all past,
present, and future as a whole thing.
And he said, your husband, my friend is just
over the next hill.
He's still there.
We can't see him where we are now, but we
are on this landscape with him and he still
exists just as much as he ever has.
Einstein believed that you right now have
been dead for trillions of years, but you
haven't been born yet.
That everything that's happened to you, if
you could get the right perspective on the
universe, you could see all at once.
So modern physics has required us to really
let go of the idea of time as something that
just flows.
We can measure that it's changing around us
all over the place-- satellites, particle
accelerators, anything going fast-- and it
may be that space and time are the same thing
all wrapped up together